uh there's a um
i sent this article to ben this was
really strange and uh
you know usually when people sue
i always go like you know do you really
need to sue because we're such a
litigious
country every billboard is like sue them
there was a billboard when i was growing
up
my dad used to pass on the highway it
was called 1-800 sue them
um and that was the billboard and it was
about uh
you know your ability to sue anyone for
any reason at all
that's the type of country that
you know we have we have a country where
the legal system
you know basically exists as a uh you
know a place for personal vendettas
for get-rich-quick schemes
um
as a way to arbitrate
any and all
uh disagreements
but then there are things where you go
okay i get it
i get it now whether you're a fan of
lawsuits or not to handle problems
there are certain stories where i go oh
i could see that i could see a lawsuit
there
that makes sense to me
black mom sues la unified
which i believe is a school district
over a cotton picking project at
elementary school
yep
this is going to be one of the lawsuits
that i can understand
a black parent filed a civil rights
lawsuit last week against the los
angeles unified school district and the
board of education saying that a cotton
field was set up at an elementary school
in 2017 that was intended to teach
students
about the experiences of slaves
reshonda pitts had a 14 year old
daughter who was referred to as sw in
the lawsuit experienced emotional
distress
as a result of the project at laurel
spann school that her social justice
teacher
said was to help students quote
gain a real-life experience
as to what african-american slaves had
endured
oh boy
the suit also names the school's then
principal
and social justice teachers defendants
since the project
laurel span school was closed and a new
school laurel cinematic arts creative
tech magnet
was created in its place
um
she said in september of 2017 her
daughter who used to vibrantly share her
day with her mother
became very quiet and reserved
um and you may imagine this one day as
pitts
was dropping off her daughter on campus
she saw a cotton field in front of the
school
and called the office to speak with the
school's principal amy diaz
who was unavailable
pitt spoke with the assistant principal
who explained that her daughter's class
was reading frederick douglass's
autobiography and that the cotton field
was created so students could have a
quote real-life
experience of slavery
well
they had a whole big thing
this was right over in west hollywood
of course
of course it was
they had a whole big uh thing
and uh so she didn't have to pick the
cod and her daughter
um but she had to watch other students
complete the project while she was while
she cared for other crops in the garden
i mean god
god god help us
so i like they say well we're teaching
the white kids about
what happened
uh
with slaves so they're gonna have to
pick the cotton but why don't you go
tend to some okra
or some other uh vegetables in the
garden
so they have to have
they are making a black girl tend to
vegetables in a garden
while watching white people do the
cotton thing and this is a good idea
this was someone's idea of a good idea
um
and now there's a lawsuit
and there's a lawsuit now
i don't know how much emotional distress
the uh daughter uh experienced i imagine
it's something
but
a jury will decide
but again it's one of those things where
i go
of all of the things
that
people sue over
if your daughter came to you and said i
uh your black daughter came to you and
said i uh
today at school they did a project where
we picked cotton
to learn about the experiences of slaves
i can imagine that you would be upset
about that
that would not go over
big
so there is a lawsuit
and um
we don't know what'll happen
we are
waiting here
with baited breath
we don't know
um
sad
they tried to change the name of the
school
they tried to
but this is gonna follow them it's gonna
there's no getting around this
the problem with this is when people
when people start to use their
imagination
and they're trying to be good people
they tend to do the most horrific things
that have ever been done
this is not uncommon
when people are trying to be good people
and they don't know how to be
and they think they can
flip a switch
and understand something
or
be a quote part of the solution
uh on the right side of history
whatever it is um
and they start using their
imagination they start being creative
about how to do
that uh
the horror
is unending
it's uh terror
will be unleashed
they will do things
that they think are genuinely good
um
until
people see them and go what the [ __ ]
is this
i mean they will literally
i mean the idea that they had a cotton
field
in front of the school
like they had to this was not an
accident
this was planned
it happened
with the full knowledge of many many
people
that had to sign off and go this is a
good idea let's get the kids out there
let's get them picking cotton
that then they'll understand what the
slaves went through
if they have to pick cotton
in front of the school
insane
but this is what happens when you have
people
that are going like how can we
creatively
show children what slavery was like
instead of worrying about
other things you go how can we let's put
our heads together
how can we recreate slavery today
for the kids
no no i know i know we got the math test
but
we want them to feel
the lashes on their back
and the calluses on their hands
we want to recreate
chattel slavery
today at school
how can we recreate settler
colonialism
after lunch
yeah
that's a bad idea
this is a bad idea this is not a good
idea this is the opposite of that
but this is not surprising i know some
people that
would do something like this thinking
that it is good
you know
no we built a gas chamber in the
gymnasium
to teach the kids about
what do you mean you're upset
what are you upset about
how are they gonna know
what the holocaust was like
if we didn't build a gas chamber in the
gymnasium
we wanted to give the kids yes well some
of the kids got to be little nazis
and then some of them got to be jewish
people it's uh
it's to because they're becoming better
people
what is wrong